hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the ftx crypto cup
we know the first finalist that is of
course wesley saw and now we need to
figure out who will be the second
finalist it's uh magnus carlsen versus
tamora jabo and this is their game four
of the second match magnus one game one
then game two and three ended in a draw
uh rajabo had a well he had a really
great chance to beat magnus with the
white pieces in game three but magnus
was able to draw that game
and now uh it's all up to tamer to win
the game with the black pieces how will
he do that well he tries a
most interesting opening uh so without
further ado let's check it out
magnus opens with e4 and rajab goes
b6 so he goes for the owens defense uh
we have d4 by magnus bishop to b7
attacking the e4 pawn and now
bishop to d3 and now just e6
for those of you who are maybe new to
the channel there is a famous joaquino
greco game
from the 17th century uh that
only takes seven moves so i'm just going
to show it to you really quickly
black attacks the center with with f5 we
captured this pawn
allow black to capture our g2 pawn so we
kind of offered the rook here but now
queen to h5 would check g6 and now
f captures on g6 knight to f6 black
attacks are queen
and now we happily give up the queen by
capturing this pawn here it's very
important that we capture this one
because it defends the g6 square
and now after knight captures bishop to
g6 is checkmate so one of the nicer
games that
were ever played in in chess so
yeah if you haven't seen it i imagine
it's quite a nice one
so that being said uh here tamer just
played e6 we have knight to f3
and now d6 we have castles by magnus and
the knight to d7
uh we have a4 grabbing more space on the
queen side a6 and now
rook to e1 and here there are some games
where g6 was played but here we have
knight g to f6
and it is now already as of move seven
uh that we have a completely new game
magnus goes knight b to d2
we have bishop to e7 and now knight to
f1
so magnus is not going for anything
crazy because tamar chose
such an offbeat opening he just wants to
put his pieces on most optimal squares
and say uh yeah i'm very happy with the
draw with the white pieces uh
then i go to the finals and i face
wastely so so it's up to tamer to
figure out how to post some problems so
here we have castles
knights to g3 and now e5
we have c3 magnus says i'm very happy to
trade here
we have rook to e8 and now bishop to d2
so still no captures or or for any
pieces or pawns
we have bishop to f8 now the rook is
very strong on the e file
and now b4 by magnus we have g6
and now queen to c1 preparing to trade
off the dark square bishops at some
point
we have bishop to g7 and now well you
could play this
magnus first starts with a5 uh we have
beef
b5 by tamar now closing over the
position on the queen side and
now bishop to h6 and magnus is playing
this very carefully
and very very slowly he is already down
to some 10 minutes on the clock whereas
rejabu has some 14 minutes on the clock
i think some 13 and a half
so here we have bishop the h8 still
avoiding
any and all trades but now this means
that carlsen's bishop is now a monster
on h6
but rajabo has to try we have d5 now by
magnus now closing the
center as well now we can see that the
queen side is closed the center is
closed
and now all that can open up is
basically the king's side and this is
what magnus wants
so here we have c5 trying to uh maybe
do some damage here maybe ruin the
white's pawn structure if white
happens to capture on c5 but magnus just
plays h3 he doesn't really care about
this if he was
trying to go uh aggressive then maybe he
could capture
but there there's really no reason to do
this or maybe he would probably capture
the captures on c6 alpha song
but he just says okay you play whatever
you want i'm i'm happy with the draw
here
so here we have c4 further closing the
position bishop to c2 and now
knight to f8 we have queen to d2
and now comes the bishop the c8 shifting
the bishop over to this diagonal
here it will be much more useful but now
knight the h2 here magnus is ready
to include this rook into the game
because now with the queen side being so
close you can shift this rook to f1
shift this rook to e1
or maybe even shift this rook to f1 play
f4 play rook f3 bring this rook to f1
double up on the f file
so there's all the time in the world
because still no pieces or pawns were
exchanged and rojo is
he's basically just waiting for magnus
to kind of start being brave go for the
attack and then maybe he can look for
his chances
as uh well arajabo is a spectacular
counter attacker
so here we have bishop the g7 and now
offering a trade of the
dark square bishops uh and here you
could go for it for example captures
captures and then immediately bust open
with f4
but here just rook to f1 magnus playing
it slowly
uh with bishop captures queen captures
and now king the h8 here rajabo wants to
play knight to g8
and sort of trap the queen on h6 not
really trap because for example if f6
knight g8 you can play queen g5 but then
we trade queens
and then rajavo is very very happy
playing these close the
structures maybe he can you know uh
maybe he can do something but okay after
king h8 magnus just
brings the queen back with queen to d2
and now comes
knight six the d7 now jabba also wants
to
um open up uh well the position with
moves like uh
like f5 and also uh if f4 is played
then this pawn can capture and then the
knight will have a very nice outpost on
e5 and here
uh there is one move that tamer could
have tried instead of this and this is a
such an interesting move because uh the
queen already retreated but now we
we actually can play g5 here and it's a
pretty crazy move but i think it's
just the the kind of move that rajab
would enjoy playing
and now if the queen captures now uh we
have this g6 square for our knight
then we bring the king over to g8 we can
maybe even move some pieces here
rook to g7 bring the other rook to g8
and pose some problems for the white
king because
as long as this bishop is on c2 hitting
his
own pawn not much is happening for white
so while this is objectively better for
white maybe this was you know
right up uh rajab of sally to find
something like this but okay
after queen to d2 he plays this move he
of course is
ready to bring this knight over to e5 uh
and now comes
f4 by magnus so it was only a matter of
time before this gets played
e captures on f4 rook captures and now
knight
to e5 magnus immediately counters this
knight knight
to f3 we have knight after d7 and now
rook to f1
so now our job of trades once we have
captures captures and now the other
knight comes to e5 we have rook to f6 by
magnus
and this is definitely the absolute best
because you do not want to allow this
queen to go
for example to h4 so rook to f6 gets out
of
harm's way and also just prevents the
black king from entering the game and
here
you can see that all of these squares
are unavailable to the light square
bishop so
it's it's a very sad bishop again it's
like this entire tournament is one big
saga of the satellite square bishop
uh but okay uh from black uh so here
we uh really don't have a good move
rajab could just make moves and wait for
for carson to slowly slowly improve his
position
but there is no time for that he plays
bishop to f5 and now he says all right
now i've uh broke coordination between
your rooks you cut from my bishop i'm
going to capture your rook but magnus
does this very happily uh because he
will get a
a massive attack for this so he captures
an f5
queen captures on ease on f6 that was an
accidental arrow if anyone saw it
uh f captures on g6 now with an attack
on the queen also the
bishop is guarding the spawn so queen to
h4
and now you don't even have to do
anything with the pawn you might go for
the trick g7 check if the king captures
then we just
win the queen with knight to f5 check
but you don't have to do it you can just
move the king
and then we basically will get the exact
same position that happened in the game
so instead after queen to h4 magnus went
knight to f5
and now queen to h5 magnus of course now
played the g7 check
king to g8 and now even knight captures
on d6 so eliminating
uh the defender of this knight here and
also now when the knight moves you will
have
uh well all the path will be cleared up
for this past the d-pawn
so here we have rook eat the d8
attacking the knight knight now
goes back to uh to f5
now the pawn is again defended uh we
have f6 making some reading room for the
black king but now
d6 and this is just uh terrible for for
jabba uh the queen is now coming to d5
this will come with
check you have to be very very careful
here so he plays rook to
f's rook to a7 to help uh defend the the
black king with rook to f7
but now magnus just plays queen to d5
check rook to f7
and now we get into the almost almost
into the final position of the game
where magnus just played a beautiful
beautiful move uh so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find this idea
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who found any
move here congratulations because any
movie is winning here for white you
could play anything you could play
rook to e1 you could push the pawn to d7
you could really try anything but the
move magnus played i think is the nicest
one because he played bishop to d1
and this is just i think the most poetic
and to the
uh to the semifinals because now the
black queen is under attack and
there really is no good square for the
black queen uh
you could put it on a very passive
square of course if you go somewhere
like queen to g6
uh then uh there are some ideas for
example knights the e7 check
could be a nice one uh the problem is uh
after king captures and
knight captures and g6h captures it
still maybe
possible to at least pose some problems
so it's not the cleanest way but it is
uh
it is completely pointless to play this
with black and on the other hand after
bishop to d1
you don't really have any other good
choices if you go some like queen to g5
now h4 is coming and
that queen just uh has no squares uh
this is taken by by the rook this is
taken by the knight you could bring the
queen all the way to c1 for example but
if queen to c1
then we get this bishop to h5 now with a
double attack and this is just
torture there there there is no there is
no point in playing this
so after this bishop to d1 move uh
rajabo resigned and this means that
wesley so is uh already wesley is
already in the finals which means that
magnus carlsen
will face wesley so in the finals of the
ftx crypto cup so this is
this will be uh magnus's third encounter
against wesley so in the finals
of such a tournament and the magnus lost
the previous two encounters so this will
be a great opportunity for magnus to
exact his revenge or will uh wesley go
for a hat trick and prove that he
is indeed the greatest world champion so
once again we will have a
nice clash of world champions in the
finals and uh well
we'll see uh what happens and will
magnus be able to
to take him down or will wesley continue
to reign supreme
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a very nice uh end
to the to the uh semifinals at a job of
almost had it but
you know almost is never really had it
uh i would like to thank jonathan linder
david bragging uh
mb ride rodrigo rivera riverdenera
uh and suresh kota for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the fc fdx
crypto cup finals
uh with uh magnus facing the undefeated
wesley soul
so yeah thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend